raiders looking to find their winning
ways out on the east coast this weekend
and a game right here on cbs
john treach is here to tell us why they
can't underestimate the winless jets
john
yeah david it's a tough sell the
unintentionally funny hall of fame
includes vanilla isis ninja go ninja go
ninja go yes the 2006
box office hit wicker man starring
nicholas cage
and these 0-11 new york jets if the
raiders want to rise they need to beat
the team
that's funny at rock bottom they're all
professionals yes even the jets it's
important to prepare as if it's the
super bowl this week because if you
think beating the jets is unimpressive
consider the calamity of the alternative
new york is on a collision course to
becoming just the fifth team in 55 years
to finish an nfl regular season without
a win
the raiders are trying to find every
reason to take them seriously including
giving new york's defense and long time
defensive coordinator greg williams
respect
they're physical man they are really
physical they fly to the ball and they
can really hit
they've had some good defensive
performances statistics
don't always show what the film shows
you know they've been put some terrible
situations with field position
they've been out on the field quite a
bit in some of these games
been forced to take chances and greg
williams defenses are always the same
they're
very multiple they can really hammer you
with
pressures and confusing looks but you
know they're going to be ready
on defense you know they're going to be
physical and
john gruden said it all with the
straight face game time again is that
sunday at 10 a.m on channel 8 the
raiders lost last year at the jets it's
important to learn from history this
week and not
turn out like a vanilla ice music video
david